earthquake early warning systems can
give people crucial seconds to move to
safety
but only if they get the message in time
now scientists are shaking up what we
know about such systems new research
suggests that giving people enough time
to act before a sizeable tremor may also
mean sending out a few false alarms all
earthquakes start with P waves which are
fast moving and cause little damage s
waves come next they move more slowly
but cause more destruction current early
warning systems measure ground movement
during the fast P waves to predict how
much shaking the S waves will cause and
then send out an alert P waves are fast
compressive waves that push and pull the
ground in the same direction as the wave
causing little noticeable ground
movement S waves while slower move the
ground up down inside to side
perpendicular to the direction of the
wave causing great amounts of damage
warnings can be transmitted much faster
than S waves move giving people time to
take action before the damaging waves
hit to find out how much warning time
these alerts could give people
researchers imagined a system where
people could set their own alerts based
not on the actual magnitude of the quake
but on how violent the tremors would be
at their location from barely noticeable
to very strong scientists then
calculated how big the earthquake would
need to be to cause those levels of
shaking at different distances some 110
kilometers from the epicenter for
example would experience much more
severe shaking from a lower magnitude
earthquake than a person 100 kilometers
away finally researchers estimated how
long it would take to send out an alert
because a more powerful earthquake takes
a longer time to develop alerts took
longer to produce if they were triggered
by larger magnitude shakes in fact
people and most distances from the
epicenter would receive no warning at
all before a large s wave hit
but predictions for low-level shaking
could be sent out quickly giving people
tens of seconds to act the downside many
users could see the alerts as false
alarms if the quake never develops into
a more powerful tremor but if it does it
could save lives trains could slow down
and planes could delay takeoffs until
the threat passes that means that even
alerts generated for small insignificant
quakes could be incorporated into
earthquake preparedness training so that
people are ready when the big one really
does hit
you